[Musique]
je m'appelle Sylvain et je suis un Américain
qui est retourné sur la terre de mes
ancêtres la
Suède ensemble les parents ont
droit à toi 480 jours je crois avec le
congé parental et trois mois
sont réservés à chaque partenaire donc il y en a
trois  mois que la femme doit
prendre ou vous le perdez et que l'homme
doit prendre ou vous le perdez
[Musique]
donc je remarque qu'il y a plus de femmes sur
le lieu de travail, plus de femmes qui prennent
des initiatives dans tous les domaines que
vous n'entendez pas  presque autant de
commentaires du type comment conciliez-vous
travail et vie de famille, comment gérez-vous
vos enfants et votre carrière ici parce que c'est
tout à fait normal, comme tout le monde le fait, hommes
et femmes
[Musique]
Je n'ai remarqué aucune corrélation entre les sexes
dans les salaires  il y a une large gamme de
salaires pour les hommes et les femmes, donc certains
de mes collègues masculins ont gagné un
peu plus que moi, mais certains ont aussi
gagné moins et il en va de même pour mes collègues féminines.
[Musique]
il est extrêmement important ici que les filles
et  les garçons et tout le monde comprennent qu'ils
peuvent être tout ce qu'ils veulent,
indépendamment de facteurs comme le genre.
[Musique] le
féminisme n'est pas un gros mot ici, bien
sûr, il y a encore des débats à ce sujet
et il y a encore des gens, en particulier des
hommes, qui ne pensent qu'à la radicalité.  féminisme
quand ils pensent féminisme, mais je dirais
qu'en général, la Suède est un pays
qui adopte le terme
[Musique] il y a
de nombreuses années, quand j'étais assez nouveau en
Suède et j'ai été flashé par un
vieil homme dans une bibliothèque publique qui était
Je me suis masturbé devant moi et pour faire
court, la police a pris cet
incident très au sérieux, elle a trouvé l'
homme qui, en fin de compte, avait fait la
même chose pour aimer sept ou huit autres
jeunes femmes dans le métro et il a été en
prison pendant plusieurs mois.  en attente de procès
et à la fin il a dû payer des
dommages importants à chacun de nous et puis bien sûr,
je veux dire que la thérapie pour des événements traumatisants comme
celui-ci est également couverte par le
système de santé et c'est comme si
c'était pris très très au sérieux.  des
valeurs humanitaires si fortes qu'il est clair que bien
sûr les gens ont la même valeur et
devraient avoir les mêmes droits,
responsabilités et opportunités et
donc bien sûr le genre est l'un de ces
[Musique] que
vous